hello everyone my name is gabriel
iglesias that's gabriel iglesias if you
have an accent i am playing the role of
speedy gonzalez hey this is don cheadle
and my character is algae rhythm hey my
name is cedric joe and i'll play
dom hi i'm malcolm d lee and i'm the
director hey there i'm siniqua martin
green
i play kamiyah james in space jam a new
legacy
here today i'm going to be taking a
buzzfeed quiz to find out what
toon squad character i am tweety party
is my favorite looney tunes character i
will say that so here we go
this should be fun how would your
friends describe your basketball skills
legendary non-existent surprisingly good
almost nba worthy so so atrocious
surprisingly good i'm gonna go
surprisingly good i do surprise a lot of
people
so so that's give me too much credit
just to make myself feel better i'm
gonna go with non-existent just so i
don't feel bad so i'm gonna go
non-existent over
atrocious so so i hope they would say
so-so
they probably say legendary legendary
next question pick a classic game boy
game tetris pokemon yellow
kirby's dreamland wario land super mario
land 2
or donkey kong land i don't know how i
don't go with super mario land 2
right i have to go with donkey kong land
my kids
are crazy crazy nintendo players mario
the wario the pokemon i love all that
stuff but i'm a donkey kong guy a lot of
these i've never heard of i'ma go with
super mario land 2 because that sounds
the most familiar and i'm pretty young
i was a huge tetris gamer tetris was my
jam i still see those tetris shapes in
my head
tetris which hannah barbera character
would you want on your toon squad
shaggy huckleberry hound judy jetson
fred flintstone
top cat yogi bear i don't know they're
all kind of a trip
let's say yogi because he's distracting
i'm gonna go with yogi
always looking for pies and treats and
you know chicken and stuff that's me
i got the belly to prove it i'm gonna
shaggy i really like his energy i don't
even think shaggy's gonna remember to
show up i'd probably go with fred
flintstone kind of use them like a shack
in front block for me and top cat wow
you guys really dug deep for top cat i
didn't even know that was a real hannah
barbera cartoon i thought that was like
one of those characters that you know
they sell on a t-shirt at a swap meet
like hey elgato the yellow gato and i'm
like okay
i'll take a yellow which of these acme
products would you buy
shrink ray gun a teleporter instant
pizza maker machine
a robot butler flying car kit magic kit
let's say a teleporter a teleporter
traffic in la is crazy
teleporter i want to go down and get a
coffee damn i can do it i want to get
home quickly i can do it the teleporter
of course definitely would not want a
teleporter from acme who knows where my
body parts will wind up
robot butler and lastly pick a food to
eat
while sitting courtside at a lakers game
nachos i've had those soft pretzels i've
had those as well
hot dog many pokeballs i haven't had a
pokeball chicken strips definitely and
tater tots
i've done five of the six but if i could
only have
one a hot dog the nachos would be too
messy the soft pretzel doesn't have
enough
poke balls that's too much going on
right there for a port side if somebody
runs into you you're going to have pokey
all over you the health person in me
says poke bowl
but that gets a little messy and on
courtside tater tots i'm a tater tot
fanatic pokeball nachos i really enjoy
nachos soft pretzel all day every day
with mustard
oh you're tweety bird i'm hoping it's
daffy duck because he's my favorite
what tweety bird it says well what do
you know
you're one fearless individual who will
always stand up for themselves
especially against bad old pooty tats
and while you may be small
you have a personality that looms large
over everyone
oh that's great that's such a compliment
i love that
small but mighty right it's really the
physicality i like the attitude of
tweeting but you know he's a little too
cutesy for me but okay
fine buzzfeed you're bugs bunny and i
got bugs money
i'm not mad at that that's what i was
aiming for you know what's up doc you're
a natural leader and the person who your
friends and family always turn to
whenever they need advice or just a good
laugh
with you it's always friendship season a
lot of that is very true i'll take that
as a good thing
thanks i'm glad to be bugs bunny i don't
know about the
family always turning me for advice i
have kids
any of you parents out there know that
that's not always the case with your
kids
everything else i'm just gonna take like
this and say
i did a good job and i crushed this quiz
you're
daffy duck of course you're anything
but despicable sure sometimes you come
off a little self-centered but in
reality you're the person in your friend
group who can always be counted on for
anything
as well as being the friend who looks
out for the best
for everyone wow still don't think he
should have been daffy but okay
fine you're despicable hey everybody
space jam is in theaters now
opens july 16th please check it out i
think you're gonna have a great time
take care
you